l'écran géant vu depuis le pare brise
c'est l'alternative aux salles obscures
dans l'allemagne en confinement
partielle de voir autre chose c'est une
super idée
en france l'idée fait son chemin en
prévision du déconfinement et le pays
pourrait s'inspirer des expériences
passées du drive-in cinéma dans notre
pays
c'est une intimité à l'intérieur d'une
voiture qui est pas du tout la même que
celle qu'on peut vivre dans une salle de
cinéma le tout premier drive in de
france c'était en 1967 à la farlède près
de toulon même si l'invention est
américaine ce n'est pas du tout outre
atlantique que le créateur de cet espace
à trouver l'inspiration
mais lors d'un voyage à naïrobi au kenya
j'avais trouvé sa sensationnelle ça
correspondait vraiment à une forme
nouvelle du cinéma classique et quand je
suis rentré en france
un jour je me suis posé la question mais
pourquoi n'at-il pas de driving en
france
au passage en caisse un haut-parleur
reliées à un fil et distribués
il n'ya plus qu'à se garer face à un
poteau et profiter d'un film depuis la
voiture je vois que décidément c'est le
cinéma des chiens aussi le drive-in
c'est de signer en toute liberté
à écouter ses spectateurs de marseille
en 1969
mais c'est agréable on est en famille on
peut fumer on peut parler on peut
commenter le film sans déranger les
voisins
seul inconvénient pour l'hiver c'est
qu'on aura beaucoup de buée sur le pare
brise
après avoir gagné le sud de la france le
drive-in à tenter de conquérir la région
parisienne ça se passe à rungis en 1970
et il y a encore un peu de pédagogie à
faire
que penser aller au drive in madam est
ce que vous pensez à aller au drive
les franciliens ont vite eu l'occasion
de découvrir le plus grand écran
d'europe à l'époque 600 mètres carrés
le tout pour 4 francs par voiture + 6 à
8 francs par personne
la recette a pris pendant quelques
années mais le ciné-parc de rungis est
devenue un gouffre financier et a dû
être fermé ses grilles aujourd'hui il
n'existe plus de ciné parcs en france
mais il pourrait revenir après le
confinement
alors que la réouverture des salles de
cinéma reste incertaine des villes comme
caen et cabourg réfléchissent à diffuser
des toiles sous les étoiles
[Musique]